Is it really surprising that the most powerful
man in the world should be a figure of controversy.
We as a population on this planet have been
looking for a savior.
We're talking about a being (alien) who's very existence (they are not telling us the truth)
challenges our own sense of priority (this is our planet) in the universe.
Human beings have a horrible track record of (tragedy)
following people with great power.
Power corrupts and absolute power (terror) corrupts absolutely. (Absolute chaos)
Maybe he's just a guy trying to do the right thing.
We know better now don't we. (He's out of control).
Devil's don't come from Hell beneath us. (They brought their warrior) No, they come from the sky.
The world has been so caught up with what he can do that no-one has asked what he should do.
Go home! Go home! Go home! Go home!
That's how it starts.
The fever.
The rage.
The feeling of powerlessness.
That turns good men
cruel.
Tell me, do you bleed?
You will.
Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie. So surprise, not
surprise, Warner Brothers decided
because of the leak they'd release the
trailer officially so this is gonna be a breakdown of that.
So there are a couple of big cities that we'll visit in the
film. Two obviously really notable ones: Gotham
and Metropolis. Here we see a statue of
Superman. This doesn't pick up too much further
after the last Man of Steel movie, not
a whole lot of time has passed.
It's going to directly address what happened in that film, how much Superman tore the city up.
Some of the voice-overs you here are Holly
Hunter, she's playing a senator.
We hear Lex Luthor in a voice-over. The
Alfred voice-over at the end is actually more telling,
about how fear can corrupt good men. He's
talking about both Superman
and Lex Luthor which I think is
interesting. Lex Luthor is always
more fun when he's not just like a
straight up villain.
There'll still be a lot of the classic dynamics in there but he's gonna be a tech
billionaire confronted with the idea
of this alien god-like creature
on earth. Clearly he's not gonna be super
happy about what's going on.
Batman on the other hand, Ben Affleck's
Batman, is also gonna be really pissed off.
The whole theme of the trailer is
everybody hates Superman. You can see in this
scene here, you know, a bunch of people worship
him but because he can't be
everywhere all at the same time people
are starting to get pissed at him.
"You're supposed to be a god, why can't you
fix everything?" Here's a pretty cool shot of him
disabling what looks like a Russian rocket.
It could be a warhead, it could be a
satellite, it could be a spaceship.
There was actually a Man of Steel Easter
egg for Wayne Enterprises,
a Wayne Enterprises satellite just got
taken out whenever the Kryptonians
came to Earth. This is really interesting
because you see a bunch of soldiers
wearing Superman symbol patches
on their arms. Either it's a police task
force that's been trying to help him
or it's a bunch of fanatics that think that
they're serving him. Superman isn't
one to court that kind of attention so
clearly he's gonna be really
uncomfortable with people treating him like a god.
And here we finally see the graffiti
"False God". This is, like, public opinion
slowly turning against him.
The interesting thing is he's never
supported the idea that he is a god
or even called himself that. Angry Bruce Wayne. This is gonna be a slightly older Bruce
Wayne than we've seen before, forty-something.
If you haven't read Frank Miller's Dark
Knight Returns comic book
it's actually, it's not a great Superman
book, it's a great Batman story, not so
great for Superman though.
That story inspired the tone of Batman versus Superman as well as a lot of visual elements.
They didn't directly take the plot or anything,
it's a complete
adaptation so it's it's entirely Zack
Snyder's story they used
changed a little bit. Here's a good shot of
the Batsuit finally,
we saw this in the teaser last night. This
question mark is a nice Easter egg for the Riddler,
probably gonna appear in one of the films at some point. Here's a good shot of the Batmobile in action.
It actually looks a lot like the Arkham
Knight Batmobile like the really
hardcore battle-ready Batmobile.
Not quite a tank like the Tumbler, a little
more agile. This is actually the best full-on shot of
Ben Affleck in costume that we've seen
so far. You definitely see a lot of
Frank Miller's Batman costume in there.
And Ben Affleck did get jacked for the
role. Here's a better shot of him in like
the Dark Knight Returns armor. He's also using a vocoder to affect his voice.
I think that's an answer to the
Christian Bale Batman voice that
everyone's just started to make fun of.
It's gotten so ridiculous. That's been
parodied so much that I totally agree with them,
that they should not try and replicate it. It's
just too silly now. "Do you bleed?
You will." There's a lot of theories that Batman
might be involved in the synthesis
of kryptonite in this film. At some point
kryptonite will become a part of this universe
but Zack Snyder said before the first Man of Steel movie that kryptonite did not exist on Earth.
There are only three ways to hurt
Superman. One, you can be stronger than him
like in the case the other Kryptonians. Two, you can use magic which we haven't seen in this universe yet.
And three, you can use kryptonite which
we also haven't seen yet.
Of those three things kryptonite is just the
most logical. I think that will flow
from some of the terraforming logic
that they set up in Man of Steel.
I know a lot of people are wondering like
where Aquaman and a lot of the other
characters are in this film.
Supposedly they're gonna have incredibly
minor roles, it's mostly gonna be Batman, Superman
and Gal Gadot's Wonder Woman. Because
this is just a teaser trailer what I
think is gonna happen is I think the
next trailer will reveal Gal Gadot.
Usually they save a lot for like the second
and third trailers so
expect a new trailer in like another
month or two. So let me know what you guys
think of the movie so far based on this footage.
I think it'll be interesting. I mean
really we'll have to see more footage before
we can pass judgment.
But I'm still doing an Arrow and Flash
Q&A, there's new Flash trailer that's
totally crazy so be sure to subscribe to
get that. Also a lot of Game of Thrones and some
more Daredevil coming this weekend.
In case you guys haven't seen it, I posted a
whole bunch of Star Wars trailers so
click here to watch the next Star Wars
Episode Seven trailer like 3, 4, 10 more times
and click here for the latest Star Wars
Battlefront 3 trailer. Thank you so much
for watching. Everybody, let's high-five.
I'll see you guys tonight.